what you can feel is that
they are why is this so
challenging right now
okay
these people
really
knew the person they lost
so
they get a chance to uh you know draw
from something real from there and you
could feel that pain uh in here and i
guess that's the thing that was
latching onto so much
what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation the trailer that we all
expected to come out has actually come
out black panther to wakanda forever
john how are you feeling you're excited
as a black man i am very of course you
are well as a latino man i'm very
excited to see some culture represented
here too absolutely andrew as a white
man how are you are you excited to see
every k ross returning here
very excited but now i'm feeling
emotional just of course of course just
we already know what i'm feeling
emotional about but uh excited uh for uh
what we're about to see as well i
imagine it's kind of strange because
you're gonna you've got a shoehold
trailer that i'm imagining a very
different trailer here so guys leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated you
could also subscribe and click that
notification bell but enough chit chat
uh let's see what ryan coogler and team
has in store for uh something that i
imagine was a massive task
[Music]
right off the bat
[Music]
[Music]
good
friends we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget yourself
that little submariner
and here we go
wow
[Music]
the makeup looks
and phenomenal entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
okay let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that was so swelling yeah oh my god
that was so oh wow i was like i i had a
feeling this would be a more serious
trailer but i was like that was very
you could feel the grievance throughout
that whole trailer and yeah and the pain
that's the [ __ ] [ __ ] oh god
rest in peace chadwick bozeman yeah oh
what is
this [ __ ] trailer
god damn it oh man it needs to okay we
need to get focused people
well that's the thing
i flashed back because you know it's
like we've seen the tony stark mural all
over the mcu since the character but it
hits you totally different to see the
mural of t'challa and to see that image
of chadwick like like any time that
shows up here from now on is i feel like
it's gonna tug your heart string i mean
you have to be like
extra sensitive with handling you know
this material and
you could they said that you would feel
the presence of chadwick boseman
throughout and it seems like what
they're really capturing here is the
loss of t'challa through every character
like so much of that harrowing
painstaking quality is here it's like
yeah you mean you got all the cool
marvel stuff of course
you know like that's normally what you
do when you watch the marvel trailers
you're like oh there's namor look at the
culture being exposed like there's stuff
i can already pick up on in terms of
plot uh that it looks like they they
they pull neymar out right like he's in
these in whatever that tank is of the
water something yeah yeah it looks like
whatever that military operation is yeah
and then it's gonna lead to a war with
the atlanteans and uh the wakandans and
ramon angela bassett holy cow she looks
so powerful in this movie he looks so
powerful oh yeah everyone does you know
despite whatever opinion differences you
have with leticia rightly she looks
freaking amazing in this movie too yeah
but i mean andrew how are you man um
again i think uh how i described how i
was gonna be earlier just really
emotional i think john just put it best
like it's one thing when you see the
mural of a character that just died as a
character but when you see something you
know the actor actually passed away just
it hits you differently and
um like you guys were just mentioning
earlier i'm glad that they're paying
respect
you know you feel you do feel the
presence of chadwick but it's done in a
very respectful way and it actually is
integral to the plot uh so i'm glad that
they're they're doing that and then
obviously you know we get to see some
really cool stuff with neymar i think we
got a glimpse too of uh riri williams oh
we definitely did yeah and then uh we
got that sick shot of uh i'm assuming
that shuri in the black panther suit at
the end that was really cool as well
yeah if you know anything about riri
williams i mean this is such a cool
character that brian michael bendis came
up with that he was they were going to
be filming a uh tv show in chicago and
uh that show got scrapped but he came up
with the idea for this character and
she's just on a different level of
intelligence and it's gonna be really
fascinating how they're going to uh and
obviously her character is also known as
iron heart uh it's going to be
interesting
it's going to be interesting to see how
they uh
integrated her into the mcu without tony
stark because that was a very big thing
in the comic book so i'm very curious to
see how ryan coogler introduces her in
this film but i really like uh just a
little glimpse of what we have seen so
far of her and i like that we're already
gonna see a little bit of the origin
story of namor that looks really
interesting as well excuse me guys holy
[ __ ]
[Music]
yeah no this is the rare occasion where
like it is a cultural moment like the
first black panther was for its own
reasons and this one is something that i
think yeah is like super touching and
it's like we all lost a little something
i mean for everybody involved who was
close to chadwick boseman obviously it
is much greater but yeah like this is
one of those movies that this is gonna
be an emotional experience and a
visceral experience and i i love the way
the film styles complement that feeling
because so much of the early parts it is
just like ryan coogler up in the
emotions which he is so good at but then
you have this other stuff that looks
like a nolan thriller or stuff that
looks like avatar 300 like and all those
movies aim for some level of like
emotional
harrowing harrowing emotional you know
expression to some degree so glad you
[Laughter]
yeah
it was just so epic and
sweeping and just so beautiful to
beholden and there's something that's
weirdly like uh cathartic about it
i need to
stop
right now
um
the one we have so many things in this
office and the one thing we don't have
are [ __ ] tissues for some reason yeah
yeah okay okay um
all right
uh yeah i just i need to take that in i
i wasn't expecting to be so so moved you
know it was more like i'm curious to see
how they're gonna do this
[Laughter]
this looks like this could be one of the
most powerful
moving experiences from
from marvel and and it's it's like they
had to work with such a
something so delicate so sensitive and
you could feel
like there's something that felt that
registered is so authentic in the in the
mood of this trailer you know and and
it seemed like i guess what i was
picking up on what's so effective about
the loss here is that
these actors seem like they they're the
ones who really need like 99 of us
didn't know chadwick boseman and they're
the ones who really knew chadwick
bozeman and when you get the sense of
this trailer is
excuse me
i'm gonna get through this i promise
this is so
awkward i've never been between two male
friends before crying
what you can feel is that
they are
why is this so
challenging right now
okay
let's breathe
just i feel like i'm making this about
like me and i don't make it about me um
the reason it's so challenging is
because the reason it's so cathartic is
because you know like from from acting
experiences you know sometimes people
have the thing of like you draw from
pain or like real life things or you
know you just dropped to the minds of
the characters and these people
really
knew the person they lost
so
they get a chance to uh you know
draw from something real from there and
you could feel that pain uh in here and
i guess that's the thing that was
latching on to so much
because you can feel it in every face
and in how the camera takes it all like
it's everybody and the song choices as
well yeah that was uh
that was yeah you know
it's the one thing that like when you
cry watching something but when you're
like just trying to talk about it yeah
yeah i can tell you this i mean this is
an obvious statement i'm going to be
bringing a whole tissue box when i see
this film [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
alrighty
well hey john wesh close this out man
guys
thank you for joining us uh hey leave a
like leave a comment on what we want to
know your thoughts as well were you as
you know affected and moved as we were
and uh hey keep an eye out we're gonna
talk about as well the other
announcements from phase five four and
five and beyond so thank you for joining
us and uh we'll see you soon